that is how you doing by the way it's
been a couple years since you and I
sneeze therapy refresh local cigar not
at all no secondhand smoke where are you
I am right now in Dallas Texas I can
smell it no no that's why I'm asking
I'm very courteous I appreciate that
when you have a nose my size I can smell
cigars through Instagram lines so I'm
okay without that kind of a gift
curiosity what book are you reading
right now what book you're reading right
now no you're always reading well well
there are two answers that one is here
we go look so I'm working on the third
volume of my Bible commentary one two
three three four there are eight of
these on my desk just Bible Bible
commentaries so I'm working on that
but I'm reading for pleasure I'm
finishing Woody Allen's autobiography
Wow how is it so far I'm almost done and
it was it was pretty riveting but Dennis
out of curiosity how many books you read
per week or per month well not more than
you and and now as well almost all my
book reading physical book is to finish
my five volume commentary on the first
five books of the Bible but my eye
the rest is I read inaudible and I read
about a book a month on audible and I
it's like it's like dessert for me I
just it's so relaxing so California in
California right now I'm assuming yes I
am indeed violating the rules regularly
I had I had a Sabbath dinner Friday
night with the seven friends of mine in
Santa Monica and I went on the radio and
I invited them to arrest me too bad
because then we could show how dangerous
Newsom and and Garcetti and the rest of
these totalitarians are I mean read my
column this week I hope your people will
read my column it's up at Town Hall calm
my own website dennis prager and I call
it rehearsal the this is a dress
rehearsal for a police state that
Americans overwhelmingly obey irrational
immoral laws and there is like even very
few people and they're considered
eccentric I mean people went for an
Easter service in their cars stayed in
their cars in the church parking lot and
the police came to disperse them this is
the United States of America in the name
of health you can suppress Liberty in
America well let's just say so that if
you don't agree with that what is the
right thing to do you're in LA once we
did Sweden was the only country on earth
that kept it cents and and if we had
done what Sweden did at the rate of
Sweden's debts we would have twelve
twenty thousand more Americans the
entire time would have died if at the
same rate of Sweden but we are it's
either twelve or twenty I don't remember
and because I figured it out earlier and
given how many people will die because
of the of the lockdown the people who
are not getting surgeries the people who
are not going through hospitals the
people who are dying at home the people
committing suicide the people going back
on drugs Dwarfs any of that plus the
ruined lives because of this this
unprecedented error in human history of
India 1 billion 300 million people 800
deaths and they they are putting people
on starvation they don't have they don't
have insurance policies like we do to
take care of them if they don't have if
they don't have food the UN just
predicted 36 countries will have a
famine because of what was just done now
this is the greatest error in the
history of the human race and I never
engage in hyperbole this is that's a
pretty strong statement to make this
wealthier ending in the human race yes
in recorded history correct you me give
me give me
an example you could say World War two
but enroll birth it was an evil but it
wasn't an error oh error okay evil
versus error so what what are some
errors that you would say so categorize
what are some errors which there's
nothing comparable the world has never
decided to make a unified error thank
God for Sweden because that's why the
quote-unquote experts one of the most
I'm trying to not overstate because I'm
so angry at them they are the most
overrated group of humans on earth
experts are almost all idiot savants
they know their field and they have no
wisdom so they are worthless
worse than worthless two million
prediction of deaths in the United
States and everybody panic half the
deaths in Sweden by the way are in
nursing homes Wow
interesting stat half this half the
deaths in Sweden or nursing homes so so
so you're President Trump you're
President Trump you I know you and I
talked about you running for office one
time you said you had no desire but
let's just say you're president Trump
president dennis prager you're getting
news that a virus is spreading in Wuhan
China okay and it comes out you know yes
there is a virus yes it's out there
you're seeing some of the stuff that's
taking place it's around late February
March everybody's starting to give you
advice on what to do you're hearing this
name popping out Anthony Fowler you
worked on aids back in the 80s and and
all these names are coming up what are
you doing if you're the president you
stopped flights from China which he did
by the way and was attacked by Joe Biden
for doing so you don't hear about that
in the New York Times but it's it's it's
on the record
he attacked the president I was January
31st if I'm not mistaken and he that's
when the president against all peoples
all that's racist xenophobic you know
you're it's part of your war against
China but he was right to do so
but I would never have said all of
America you can no longer work
we will shatter tens of millions of
lives we will send people back to drug
use we will we will end your dream of
the business you started the right now
what is it fifty something thousand
Americans in in in 1957 we law what was
it fifty-seven yeah a hundred twenty
thousand Americans when we only had 200
million Americans so be a hundred eighty
thousand they didn't close one business
they didn't close it in for the for the
Hong Kong flu in 69 when over a hundred
thousand Americans died we are a new
people we are cowards we believe that
that safety is God when I want to be
safe safe is a new word in lights like
no safe spaces the movie Adam Carolla
and I made it's about the colleges all
this somebody coming to college you
don't agree with please go to a safe
space where you can have will give you a
play-doh and hot chocolate and stuffed
animals I'm not kidding that is what is
given to the college kids if somebody
comes to college and they don't feel
safe there's no such thing as safe safe
is in the grave life is not safe grow up
but we are run by the immature were who
influences who influences this decision
to be made because there was so much
pressure being made by media to shut
down and then found she recommends a
shutdown and then you got 26 27 million
people applying for unemployment checks
are being made you know all this stuff
is taking place does this kind of set
the precedents in the future when
another election year is coming up or
somebody to say well listen let's go out
there and make sure we have another
pandemic to shut down the economy again
to hurt somebody else do you see this
being a play out of a being added to a
playbook for the future it's not it's
not a question as in life it's a it's a
rule it's very hard to do something the
first time it is very easy to do
something the second time
whether it's good or bad that's a rule
of life this is just the first time they
will do it if they're Democrats have big
House Senate and presidency they will do
it for global warming because remember
this is just 50,000 or 80,000 Americans
but they believe that climate change a
ka global warming is existential it's an
existential threat meaning a threat to
the existence of the human race not not
to 80,000 the human race so if we could
close down people's work and livelihood
for for 80,000 we can certainly do it
for the human race
but but I guess my question for you
would be do you foresee this happening
again and again there's no doubt in my
mind
unless Americans object strenuously and
if they elect a Democrat then the
Democrats will have been rewarded for
being at the party now some Republicans
are for this too but generally speaking
there is a huge right left divided on
this issue so so so I interviewed a lot
of different people that have come on
board and we've sat down with them
whether it's a general Spalding or last
night it was a doctor blue tar or dr.
Judy mica or you know Gordon Chang
and some of these names you know and
while I'm mentioning it's about
coronavirus or Daniels and Martino booth
which I'm sure you know who she is the
economist there's a lot of different
stories that are coming out about what's
going on with this my biggest concern is
the following is if media has this much
control to use fear where every single
time there's a shutdown and every time
we continue doing this a lot of people
that are following my content their
small business owners their
entrepreneurs these are people that are
running a business for themselves if
every time there's a shutdown the poor
can handle it the rich can handle it
middle America cannot handle it because
other guy that was giving me a haircut
this week he came over here my main
front
guy that gives me haircuts he brought
his stepson and his stepson started
cutting people's hairs and I said sounds
everything
it's a 19 year old kid I said how's
everything he said amazing I said really
why is it amazing he says man I mean I
applied for unemployment I've made more
money in the last week than I'm in the
last two months it's amazing he's
hopeful that this continues for a few
months sir I don't see the poor doing
bad during times like this those that
are getting unemployed they're getting
better checks than they did before I
don't see the rich being affected by it
because they have money they can't
handle this for a couple of years I
don't think you're affected by this I
think you're probably gonna be fine
saying you can probably handle this
because you've made some good decisions
over your career but I see middle
America getting crushed right now at a
time like this so right confirm becomes
the following here's my concern here's
my concern I've come to work every day
since they shut it down
only three days have not been on my
office I'm on my office right now I'm
not I'm not Eddie I'm not on my house
I'm on my office I run a company I got
50 14,500 insurance agents we got 130
offices I have employees over here
slowly but surely we're getting people
to come back but we kept 20% of our
employees we're not we're not shutting
down anything but I knew there was gonna
be a risk of getting fined and what if
people complain all this other stuff I
my philosophy is this you've read more I
kind of want to hear your feedback on
this can the government just tell you
that you can't go to work and shut you
down until small business owners to not
go to work does the government have that
kind of authority to tell us what to do
with our day to day business no but
Americans have accepted it and that's
what's so scary the end of the study of
the national anthem is the land of the
free and the home of the brave well 10
years 20 years before this I I said that
is no longer true it is not the land of
the free because Americans don't value
freedom the left has convinced them that
being taken care of is more important
than liberty and that is the human
nature the left comports with human
nature get yourself taken care of that's
more important than Liberty and as as
for brave
give me a break I mean people want to be
safe my father enlisted in World War two
he didn't have to he was beyond the age
of giraffe then he had a child he was
exempt and he said I'm not gonna sit
home while while other kids get killed
fighting Hitler and the Japanese went
into the Navy was in the Pacific for
three years and if you'da said them you
know max Gregor that's that's not safe
he'd of look that you'll excuse me going
to war is not safe oh thank you that's I
didn't think of that not safe if we are
guided by safe not only is this society
over individual lives are I give you my
classic example but thirty years I've
been taking groups around the world in
cruise ships and also our land trips in
Israel so for 30 years people have
called my show and said Dennis god I
really would love to visit Israel the
Holy Land and so on but I'm waiting till
it's safe so I always said to them for
30 years then you will never go it will
never be safe don't go and I've done
every year every other year for 30 years
so so uh if I'd have led a life to be
safe I wouldn't be me I will be happy I
wouldn't have gone to 130 countries I
wouldn't have decided to conduct
orchestras I'm not a trained musician I
am self-taught but but I took the unsafe
route and and I and I did something very
challenging and that is learn to conduct
orchestras if you want to lead a safe
life you will die and on your tombstone
it will be written here lie so and so
she led a safe life and it's a pointless
worthless empty life what do you say to
people that say then is that's a pretty
irresponsible statement to make I mean
you know you say who will lead an empty
life congratulations you made your
choice you have chosen safety over
living fully everybody can make their
choice all right my job is
be clarifier this is the choice you have
made you have chosen safety over living
my task in life is not to live forever
this will come as a shock we all die
since we all die I am much more
interested in living fully than not
dying and this has become a very big
filtering system because your notice and
how many people are fine with it and how
many people are not but I believe
there's a community in the middle that
they're undecided because I'll give you
a perfect idea my family we have people
that believe in vaccine yeah people who
don't believe in vaccine and we have
people who are in the middle I was in
the military and I got the moment I
joined the army they gave me 11 shots on
my shoulder and it was our guest here
you go and we have to sign something
saying if something happens to you later
on your government property for eight
years we're sorry we did this for we're
testing and it gave us all these
vaccines and we took them but we get
these heated debates with vaccines right
you shouldn't do it it's a propaganda
it's a gates it's this it's that there's
a lot of people in America forget about
the people that say a anti vaccine and
people that say Pro vaccine and they're
not willing to be to change their minds
I'm talking about people in the middle
right now in America that are saying I I
do want to go back to work I don't want
my business to go out of business but I
also don't want to do to irresponsible
thing because I want to hurt my family
those who are in the middle if you could
take a minute or two to give them a an
argument to say here's why you ought to
consider opening up outside of what you
just said which was brilliant you want a
little safe life go for it but I'm
talking about to the people that are not
arguing they want to be so if you can
give me a good argument there the jury
they're sitting there saying Dennis
please sell me on why I ought to be more
open to it
what would you say to them if you're not
over 75 and you don't have a underlying
illness your chance of dying from kovat
19 is approximately the same as your
chance of getting killed in a car
accident therefore I suggest you not
drive to work either in fact I don't you
shouldn't walk to work either you may
get hit by a car
people are ignorant as to the risk on
this issue it is almost impossible for a
child to die from coke at 19
they are more likely to drown in a
bathtub then die of kovat 19 if they are
a child we should never have closed the
schools that they didn't close the
schools in in in Sweden and I don't
think in Singapore but I'm not certain
about Singapore but they didn't in
Sweden so I it the ignorance is is
direct the ignorance is created by the
panic of the most irresponsible
institution on earth the media 24/7 news
is a curse
I don't watch I am happy I listen to
music I read constantly I know more
about this virus than the vast majority
of laypeople I have to I have to report
on it three hours a day on my radio show
I have to write about it in my column I
am up on this issue I follow it avidly
and the risk is minuscule if you are
healthy you will you'll prompt you may
well get it not probably you may well
get it it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter the group 80% of the people who
get it don't even know it
the dennis by the way if you're from
sweet and comment below that you're from
Sweden I just saw five people saying I'm
in Sweden I'm curious to know if you're
from Sweden do me a favor and come and
give me a pen if you don't mind if
you're from Sweden comment and let us
know how are things in Sweden or
Singapore let us know if you can just
kind of give us an update how things are
in Sweden I saw a handful of people say
they're from Sweden so okay then it's
next question so let's just say we go
the way we're going right now shut down
stays the way it is in California and
they'll a get Garcetti likes it in LA
new some lags it and they're going
through what they're going what what is
the consequences of this I saw somebody
ask this question what are the
consequences of this 5-10 years from now
not short term or long term I I don't I
don't make such predictions because it's
impossible to know I can only say that
the de Mai they what I just read was
about 1/3 of mom-and-pop business
we'll go out of business so therefore
whereas you now had Jerry's restaurant
you will now have another another
another chain another subway another
Chipotle or or what have you
so you will still be able to eat but it
will end the or begin to end the ability
of people to run what we really enjoy
which is a local restaurant where you
know the people they know you where the
food is better than at a chain and so
that the country will be run by gigantic
businesses and instead of the great joy
of America which is exactly that middle
class that you were that you were
talking about that you were referring to
so it's the only good thing that might
come out of it is more people will will
not send their kids to college for
$70,000 a year waste there more that's
the one silver lining I could see in
this I got wasteland from a Sweden who's
saying restaurants and gyms are closed
their path they didn't shut down you
cannot visit elderly homes is what he's
saying
nothing's closed the only thing they
have is you cannot go to a place with
more than 50 people that's exactly
correct he got it right half the deaths
in Sweden are in elderly homes by the
way which is an unbelievable tragedy but
it should show you how little the risk
is to the rest of the of humanity
interesting very interesting Denis
somebody asked the question what are
your thoughts about Bill Gates it's a
handful of people I've been asking this
question what do you think about Bill
Gates I think that the belief in America
that if you make a lot of money you have
wisdom is one of these stupidest notions
the human species can hold there is no
relationship between making a ton of
money and wisdom you you are only good
at one thing which is fine I don't knock
it you're good at making money do we
care what great shortstops think
anybody talking to Derek Jeter I am is
interested in Derek Jeter's views in
about the world as I am and Bill Gates
Derek Jeter's the great shortstop Bill
Gates is a great entrepreneur so what so
whose opinion suit would be concern
about if you're saying people who have
earned people who have earned our right
to be considered wise that's it they're
the only people only but because we
don't value wisdom any longer secular
society values knowledge not wisdom so
we think if you're a professor you will
have good advice but there is no
correlation between knowledge and wisdom
and there's no correlation between being
a billionaire and wisdom this is this it
is the age I wrote about this 25 years
ago we live in the age of non wisdom so
I'm sorry Dennis whose advice do you
take so if you're saying Sal there are
there are so many people that I that I
believe are wise including my best
friends I have friends who were 50 times
wiser than Bill Gates then they run
rings around Bill Gates about it with
regard to wisdom or or the people that I
read people I read on the internet like
Victor Davis Hanson the who happens to
also be a professor that guy is wise and
you know the what's the professor of
course in Toronto me in names you know
the you know the Peterson yes
that man has wisdom there you wisdom is
earned I earn your I have a billion
views a year at Prager you
I have 600,000 views every week to my my
fireside chat I have X numbers of
readers I have earned these people's
respect over the course of a very long
life that's how it works you that is the
reason most of the time in the past we
have we have generally a so
in an older age with wisdom because not
because they only because they've lived
longer but because they have earned with
the respect of people you don't look to
a 20 year old for wisdom and when I was
20 I didn't assume I had any I knew I
have to learn from others
we're not asking 20 year olds what
should we do about that about the virus
they could be brilliant they could be a
Harvard genius but we don't care because
they didn't earn our our the the
credentials of wisdom man is that that
could sound a little bit arrogant well
let me let me let me argue and you can
come back and answer this one some may
say Bill Gates has also earned the
respect and the wisdom from people who
follow it for decades anybody you're
right and anybody so you you who listen
to Gates you have to ask yourself am i
am i listening to him because of his
wealth or because of his wisdom if he
has earned the right for you as a wise
person listen to him I think he's a fool
but if you think he's wise obviously
why do you sorry because the things that
he has said now what would regard he's a
totally he who lives in this mansion who
who goes anywhere he wants he I don't
even think literally I don't think he
can identify with the guy who's lost his
business and I don't blame him I don't
think it's possible in general to
identify with people in completely
different circumstances we can
sympathize it is almost impossible
I can empathize with with with my wife
who gave birth like okay I can't
emphasis infant empathize with
childbirth I can sympathize but I can't
empathize I don't think Bill Gates can
empathize with the guy who has just lost
his life savings because because of this
lockdown Bill Gates knows what's gonna
happen with regard to kovin know better
than I do and probably worse Dennis you
sound like a just so you know you sound
like a liberal talk show host because
you're you're calling out a billionaire
entrepreneur you're a conservative what
do you say to people that say Donald
Trump is ability but it is to go
olá you're breaking up wait you're
breaking up a drop although I say to
people who say Donald Trump is what so
what'd he say to people that say Wally
this president he doesn't know what it
is to be Middle America he's Ben
Richards entire life you're right it's
wrong
I don't say he does to relevance are
irrelevant
uh you're saying listen to people that
have wisdom so this young somebody who
is rich doesn't have the wisdom to know
no no I was only mentioning not at all
or there are rich people who have wisdom
they report people with wisdom wisdom
does not know all I'm saying is ask
people think people think that if you
have a PhD you have wisdom people think
if you have a lot of money you have
wisdom both are wrong PhD means you have
knowledge and only knowledge in the area
you have a PhD in and people who have a
billion dollars clearly I mean I admire
gates tremendously for what he did with
Microsoft it's a revolution it's
astonishing I I thank him for his
inventions but I have zero interest in
his views on the virus or the lockdown
he's not earned my my attention span in
that regard if he had something to say
about computers I would tune in in a
nanosecond so okay so now let's let's
separate the gates and let's separate
Trump so do you believe in Anthony found
she's wisdom no Anthony found she all
the Anthony foul she knows is medicine
his he he should talk about a lockdown
as much as Derek Jeter the famous Yankee
shortstop I am told these people their
record the record of these people the
only reason this happened is because of
the people in his profession who said
2.2 million Americans will die so far
50,000 have and if you believe it's
because of the lockdown I have a bridge
for you because Sweden didn't have a
lock down and and it has a tiny
percentage more of deaths than we do but
they didn't
didn't shatter their economy by the way
do you know how many people I don't know
if I I think I said it to you a three
the maybe I didn't the United Nations
the UN tamata fana
the UN just issued a report Nicholas
Kristof reported this big liberal
columnist New York Times three dozen
countries will experience famine because
of this lockdown the number of people
who will die because of the lockdown may
be greater than the number of people who
died because of the of the illness the
starvation that will take place the
people who you know there was an article
about a product you know poor people in
Cambodia I was in Cambodia these people
are still shell-shocked from from the
genocide that happened in their country
in the 70s under the communist regime
and and they're finally getting out of
it and now everything they sell to the
west nobody's buying and that was there
that was their stepping stone out of
poverty
same thing in Bangladesh it's it's a
trap what is happening in the world
because of this idiocy India of a
million a billion 300 million people wah
sends people out of work in the hundreds
of millions eight hundred people have
died in India there probably more people
who were run over by by cows in the
course of a year in India that was a
joke for the record but I understand
what you're saying I get what you're
saying it's it's a little bit confusing
for the audience right now a lot of
people are saying I'm getting confused
and here's why I think they're saying
they're getting confused and I'm
watching them they're saying that this
wisdom thing is confusing so I asked it
you said if I want to talk to somebody
about entrepreneurship and technology
I'll talk to gates okay because yes
wisdom and hypothetically Trump is Trump
then I said Anthony foul a then he said
Anthony found she doesn't have wisdom in
the area of lockdown
Anthony foul she was asked when we
should stop the lockdown and he said
when we approach zero deaths that's
that's answer is idiocy idiocy it's not
just not wisdom it's it's the opposite
of
it is completely destructive can you
elaborate yes the the amount of
suffering and death that is caused by
the lockdown is infinitely greater than
a than a handful of Cova deaths as you
approach zero I it's beyond belief okay
you know or at worse Cuomo who's all
listened what listen to Governor Cuomo
he's so impressive Governor Cuomo said a
month ago I play it on my radio show
regularly if my lockdown of New York
state saves one life I will go to bed
happy what becomes a priority at a time
like this what is the priority is it
together all right here is here is the
key to becoming an adult most for your
young listeners here's a revelation most
people never become adults they they
grow they get older but they don't
become adults you become an adult when
you decide to become an adult one of the
keys of being an adult is to always ask
this question what is the price a child
doesn't understand that an adult should
everything comes with a price if you get
married what is the price of marrying
well it's the price of staying single
what is the price of having children
what is the price of not having children
that is the mature way to lead life
always at what is the price of putting
tens of millions of Americans out of
work what is the price of not what is
the price of depriving people of the
right to to go around i broadcast from
Glendale California they made an
announcement even if you are walking
your pet you have to wear a mask of
course I don't wear a mask when I take a
walk in Glendale California
I hope they arrest me these pee
are fools running Glendale California
and most other cities because I'll tell
you why cuz they don't know what they're
talking about they have no idea how it's
communicated and they want to look they
have a new this is the new motto in
America the new motto is better safe
than sorry
and that's it that's the motto of the
country that's why the country may fail
the United States of America is an
experiment
in Liberty and bravery we are showing
nibel problem I'm curious for everybody
that's watching this right now how many
guys lost your jobs or you run a
business and you're about to shut down
your business if you lost your job or
you are about to lose your business
comment below I'm curious to know how
many people come through that challenge
right now how about the stimulus how
about all these times that we're bailing
out another check and another check
another check another check and other
chicks like dj khaled another one it's
costly another check coming out how long
can we sustain this sending checks to
people well according to the left
forever the the that the country will
keep printing monopoly money does not
trouble them because their view is the
more people dependent upon the
government the greater the power for the
Democratic Party and their right that's
exactly right what's why all government
records vote Democrat and almost all a
middle class of business owners both
Republican people who take care of
themselves and others they vote
Republican people who are taken care of
they vote Democrat so both statement
right there it's a very bold statement
right there when you're saying well it's
either true or not true I don't know if
it's bold
yeah but yeah I I'm not I'm not I'm not
far off with you disagreeing on this
I've run a sales organization I can tell
you there's people that are constantly
wanting leads and are those that go find
their leads typically the guys that find
their leads they don't care if you give
them leads they're fine if you don't
send them leads because they figure out
a way to make their own money those who
rely on
are the ones that typically complained
the most I don't know why this law is in
the world of sales but some of it
applies also in life my father was the
president of a synagogue and I was it I
was a little kid and I'll never forget
him saying you know the people we give
free membership in the synagogue to are
the ones who complain the most yeah
that's so amazing there's so much truth
behind that you know I want to share
this with you I had a lady that called
me her and I were talking this is a
woman who one time we're having this
conversation to get and she told me she
said you know what's the closest thing a
man will ever experience to giving birth
I said what's that that's starting a
business I said tell me tell me what you
mean by that she says I've given birth
to two kids and I've started a business
she says when I gave birth to my kids in
labor lasted for 24 hours
she said well when I started a company
that ping lasted for five years every
other day we almost went out of business
it was very painful
she said what most people don't realize
is when somebody starts their own
business it is a form of their baby it
is a form of their baby that they put
the time into starting the company so
for me when I get a lot of calls that
people call me in their founders they're
entrepreneurs they run businesses I tell
them I said is this your baby yes how do
you take care of your baby I protect it
make sure you protect your baby because
no one's gonna care more about your baby
than you are and this is why you're
seeing a lot of people here in Dallas a
lady had her hair salon and she kept it
open African American lady has her hair
salon and she keeps it open and they
came down and they say you have to shut
this place down this is not an essential
business you can find me a nice place
down I'm keeping my business open
because I have to make my money I have
to go out there make my money so I'm
just what I'm most curious about Rob
Dennis is not that we disagree on a lot
of things you were saying I just asked
the question because I'm asking a
question of what some generations may be
thinking about because they may disagree
with you and I want to get some
discourse hear your part I'm curious
about is the following
how long are people just gonna say okay
okay fine
yes I'll follow the rules no problem how
long do you think that's going to last
what we do
but all of a sudden our gonna say listen
I'm just not listening to you I'm gonna
get to work in California some people
went to the beach this past weekend
because we got hot weather and I was
thrilled that they went to the beach and
governor Newsom just there made an
announcement that he's going to clamp
down with moral laws to make sure this
doesn't happen this is the the best
example one of the better not the best
but a really good example of the moral
necessity of civil disobedience which is
particularly funny since California is a
sanctuary state violating federal law on
an illegal people illegal immigrants
into the United States so he's a big fan
of civil disobedience and so am i when
its moral this this this is the this is
the test are we the land of the free or
the home of the brave or the land of
snitches mayor de Blasio told New
Yorkers to photograph people who are
gathering in you know more than two
people or whatever it is and outside and
take photos and send it to the police
this is this is truly it's what people
should read my columnist week it's at
their town hall dennis prager calm its
we did is the it is literally the
skeletal creation or the the basis of a
of a police state I never thought this
would happen in America I have to say
I'm not an optimist in life I'm an
optimist for my own life but I'm not an
optimist for the world there's been too
much evil I'm not an idiot
but I never thought that I would live to
see Americans go yes I I will do
something stupid yes I will allow my
business to be crushed because because
I'm in Idaho but or half more than half
the deaths of in America are happening
in the New York metropolitan area but I
should go bankrupt here in Idaho I I
don't think people gonna just sit around
all right well they have an hour
they have oh but I think here's what I
think about the following you know when
you got a father
and the kid is pulling on the jacket
some fathers can only take four times
some fathers are can take it ten times I
don't be running but there's no father
in the world that will let the kid do
that four days I don't think that's
gonna happen I think people are gonna
get sick of it and they're gonna respond
and once they do I've been through it
I'm from Iran so to me I'm used to this
kind of stuff this is very normal for
somebody that was born and raised in
Iran in America this is weird but to us
they came from Iran this is just another
day in Iran I mean we're right that's
correct this equal each day yeah I don't
see this thing being being being going
on too long I see people get well it's
it's listen it's astonishing that it's
gone on this long we're talking now six
weeks
I agree supposed to be 15 days it's now
six weeks well you know you you're
you're there are people who rely on
people like pouchy and Trump and the
experts to make the right decision and
when the data comes out and some of
these data guys are coming out and
projecting two million deaths by this
time and we're not hitting those that
scares the hell out of a lot of people
and a lot of people and you know the
fear tactics that's going to do you want
your parents to die do you want your
kids to die do you want this person to
die and they're using all these you know
stories that you're seen I can see that
being very effective but I just think
people realize and listen I got it
it happened yes we understand I just
need to make sure I'm ready to get back
and we're gonna get back to where Texas
just so you know I don't know if you
know what's going on this Friday with
Texas restaurants many of them are
opening up this Friday not the ones that
are corporate the corporate ones are not
opening up in Texas but a lot of a lot
of the Panisse restaurants are opening
up this Friday
my wife just text me right now she said
what restaurant you want to go eat I
said check with Fleming's Papa Bros and
she called Fleming's they're not opening
up but Fleming's headquarters you know
they're there hesitating they're not
giving green light Papa Bros they don't
know yet Capital Grille is most likely
opening up so I'm gonna have my burrata
cheese salad this Friday by the way just
say envy you I I live in in in in the
police state of California you know yeah
I see so few people have died in this
state it's by the way I'll give you
another example of how Americans are
misled they're constantly told
all the number of cases is skyrocketing
the number of cases few people not
realize that the more people who
actually have had this the better it is
it shows you how few people die what's
better if a million people let's say we
have a thousand people died in a given
state what's better than a million had
the disease or a hundred thousand had
the disease obviously a million so the
number oh my God look at how many cases
Sweden hopes it had the whole country
had cases then they're immune the number
of cases is not a bad thing the number
of deaths is a bad thing number of cases
actually a good thing but they'll never
have a guy like me on CNN and the two
doctors - two ER doctors who had four or
five million views Bakersfield
California doctors YouTube took it down
I know what's weird about it is it's
it's there's nothing weird and forgive
me it's the only time I'm disagreeing
with you the whole time it is not weird
at all but YouTube took it down Google
is a left-wing site that and you differ
with them they don't want you heard
here's what I mean by what's weird about
it
they took it down from a left-wing
network it was on ABC when they took it
down did you ever see the interview with
the CEO of YouTube would on ABC on 60
minutes did you ever watch that no I'll
text it to afterwards you have to watch
that one because you see in the ABC 60
minute ladies sitting there calling out
the sealed YouTube saying why are you
letting all these journalists keep
making content they're not journalists
were journalists we do proper vetting
and investigation and she said we're not
a journalistic site we're a social media
site she says you're not a social media
site you're a content creating
journalistic side so that the battle
going back and forth
mainstream media cannot stand a lot of
these guys that are creating content on
YouTube
but of course how are you guys doing
Prager University are you guys still
getting challenges or not that
yeah of course but we look we have a
billion views a year it's a invite your
your many many listeners and then
viewers to go to Prague are you calm if
your kids by the way you want to give
wisdom to your kids that's the place
Prager PRA ger you Prager University
calm we have we have former prime
minister is Pulitzer Prize winners
professors it's it's a very deep website
and they're all five-minute courses so
your even your kid will be able to be
that attentive but but I'm telling you
this what they bid on YouTube to these
doctors this I mean to say that the to
this is not retired people they are
currently saving lives in California at
a hospital that these people are giving
misinformation that that's really scary
Dennis how many billionaire libertarians
and independents do you know you got to
know a few them I know you and I used to
go to a what was this house Wayne Hughes
house in Malibu and we used to drive I
was like 15 years ago ten years ago
alright how many billionaire
independents and libertarians do you
know I don't I
and I don't know personally many I don't
know personally many but go on my point
is why why white is like when when CNN
Ted Turner started CNN 24-hour news
network in yeah rushed it
you know when Zach starts Facebook or
you know well Jack Dorsey Ilan all these
guys are starting what they're creating
what why aren't these libertarians in
the bath ah this is a puzzle to me Jeff
Biggio spies The Washington Post
what is it a billionaire by I was
conservative by the LA Times oh they do
Marc Benioff just bought Time magazine a
year and a half ago yeah but it's it's
it's a rag sheet Time magazine it's a
propaganda sheet it is it is the worst
Newsweek is is light-years above it at
least it has alternate opinions I agree
st. jude's why didn't somebody else buy
time I agree you know why as I've said
my whole life there's a civil war in
America but only one side is fighting
the left that's just that's evidence of
my Eve they they're they're you know
they're happy to be with their family
their business their church and you know
don't bother me with with being a being
active I think conservatives like to be
left alone and just live their lives
right that is exactly right they're the
ones that just say you know what if
there's a family gathering and there's a
fight the the liberal will fight on for
hours conservatives gonna say I'm just
going to sleep but then the growing
liberal one to fight so that's correct
yeah it more of a fight this is good I
want to see there being a fight I like
the Lakers against Chicago I like
yes my line I fight I we need one more I
think we need one more I think we need
somebody in the middle
you're a media company or a social media
company that competes with everybody and
allows content to stay on because that's
right that's all we need we don't need a
conservative site we need an open one I
want the left to have access
I have zero desire to suppress the Left
theorem to say if I have a friend and I
know this man very well is a good friend
of mine and if we can get him and a few
other names to go out there and create
an open social media platform with some
additional perks and nice gamification
aspects to it
independent independent open to
everybody left right middle up-down
whatever it is you can cut the contest
yes what would happen to create momentum
for a company like that who do you think
would get behind it well you just said
who would get behind the people with the
money to start something that allowed
everyone on and it got publicized and
kids became aware this there's an
alternative YouTube has almost a
monopoly so it's difficult to what to
compete with them and just the
staggering amount that's on there look I
I'm I'm on there a lot and I'm very
happy about that
but but it you know
it's dangerous it is truly dangerous see
the problem is this people always say to
me why don't you just thought a
conservative alternative to YouTube
since they put a hundred of your videos
on on the restricted list so I say
that's like saying you know with Delta
American and United say you can't fly
start your own airline it's not that
easy then if somebody's asking if
anybody close to you has died from
coronavirus no nobody nobody close to me
has lost their business so these these
issues are asking that question is
meaningless it's it's like people will
say if you haven't experienced it
therefore what I don't live in
Bangladesh am I not allowed to feel for
the guy who lost his business selling
jeans through American companies I mean
I might as well say so I I don't know
what the question means and I know I
wouldn't change my mind if someone close
to me
I don't face my opinions on the
tragedies of my life that's the opposite
of wisdom that's feelings that that
question is exactly what has happened in
America we have substituted feelings for
wisdom feelings for thought please
elaborate yes because what is the
question imply if if I knew somebody who
died of the corona virus I would feel
differently I might feel differently but
I wouldn't think differently how I feel
is irrelevant then we live in the age of
feelings I've written about this it's on
the internet it's called the age of
feelings in King King high school and
kids rest how do you feel about it
parents ask their kids how do you feel
about it it doesn't mean a damn thing
how you feel about it what do you think
what have you reasoned through what are
your values feelings feelings are
beautiful between two people but you
don't base moral ideals on a
give I have my classic answer who would
you say first your dog or a stranger if
both were drowning most Americans today
I've asked this question for 40 years 40
and the the ones I asked 40 years ago
are now 60 and uh I they they say oh I
would save my dog why would you save
your dog cuz I love my dog I don't love
the stranger but that in my value system
is the wrong answer
I believe human beings are more valuable
than animals because I blame her I am a
Jew who believes in the Bible just as a
Christian would and we are created in
God's image dogs or not I own two dogs
whom I love I would save a stranger
before my two dogs even though I would
feel much more love for my dog than a
stranger I don't love strangers but I do
what is right and I don't follow my
feelings that's a very deep statement
somebody could call it cold you know no
it's very warm you speak to the
strangers family afterwards who said you
know my dad was drowning why didn't you
save him and you'll say oh because I
love my dog who's cold exactly I'm on
your side I have two dogs and now if I
see a stranger I'm gonna go out there
and see them I fully understand what
some some people will call a coke some
people yes of course they will because
they assess it based on feelings cold is
a feelings issue do you think it's good
the fact that politically America is so
divided right now do you think that's a
good thing no well so you don't you
think it's a good you think it's good
that if we all got along then we agree
you think that'd be a better place to be
if we all got along with with what I
believe in it would be better if we all
got along with what the Left believes in
it would be the end of America so it
depends you know about on being on
totally honest with you with you you
would be jobless that's fine it's better
for America if everyone agreed with me
and I would be jobless I'm
there's two be jobless for America to be
a better place oh my gosh to me it's the
other way Ron I think opposition is good
because it toughen us up I think a
little bit of that is good I like the
fact life provides enough opposition
without having morons tell you that
bigger government and being taken care
of instead of liberty is a good thing
believe me life has enough challenge
without having people ruin it for you I
think you secretly love liberals because
you like a good fight
I know you're not secretly love well I
secretly love liberals but I do not
secretly love leftists I draw a big
distinction between liberal and lust or
some I know I know you explained it to
me last time but for some who don't know
the difference can you tell us yeah I'll
give you one big example leftist believe
in black dormitories and black
graduations at colleges liberals do not
liberals believe in racial integration
leftist believe in racial segregation
okay for some who don't have a PhD can
you break that down please yes many
colleges have all black dormitories the
own the last time we had all black
dormitories was in the South when it was
segregated I was raised a liberal
liberals believe in racial integration
racial segregation is dormitories based
on race I'm completely opposed to that I
don't want all-white dormitories I don't
want all yellow dormitories or red
dormitories or all black dormitories the
whole purpose of America is to integrate
is I have two neighbors I live in and I
live in a dead end
one is Arab from Syria Lebanon and one
is from Korea I love that that's and I'm
a Jew this is America but you also want
everybody to agree with what you drove
what you believe in yeah that's correct
dude the basic judeo-christian American
values that founded this country that's
a very it's a very good system it's made
a good place what are the chances of it
ever happening where everybody agrees on
the same system
for a large percentage of American
history there was a general agreement in
what I call the American Trinity the
three things that are on every American
coin Liberty eople Orbis unum meaning
from many one we come from many
backgrounds but we become American and
in god we trust' that there was a
Supreme Being who is the source of our
rights which is in the Declaration of
Independence all I asked is Americans
accept that they can differ on a
thousand other things
Dennis Kenny st. February 3 times shall
I say what three times it ready Liberty
Liberty Liberty Liberty you know what
you sound like for a second that
commercial Liberty Liberty Liberty
enough TV to have said but I would have
yeah I wish yours so look why don't we
wrap up with a little bit of
light-hearted stuff you used to do but
don't you do something on your radio
about love I don't know what it was
called was about relations yeah yeah on
my radio show which people could dennis
prager calm you can find out or write me
at Dennis pray about calm you tell you
what station and how you can hear me but
three hours a day of broadcast
Wednesday's the second hour of my show
is called the male-female hour and I'd
say it's the most honest talk about men
and women in the American media and as I
say almost every week I'm not a man fan
and I'm not a woman fan I'm a fan of
clarity and I'm a fan that they get
along better but I don't root for either
sex I I don't I don't believe one is
better than the other they're a
disgusting man and disgusting women and
beautiful men and beautiful women do you
think if you were 28 years old today 28
year old Dennis Prager would you even
think about getting married during times
like this there's no question I would
know if people got married during the
Depression people got married during
World War two
Jews got married after the Holocaust
after their whole families were wiped
out
either you believe in marriage you get
married because you believe in marriage
the perfect example of the feelings
issue well I'll get married when I feel
like getting married no you get married
because that's how you grow up ask
anyone who's been married I don't care
if they've been divorced did marriage
mature you every single human who has
been married will say yes but people
don't want to be mature they want to be
safe do you think marriage should have
terms well I have lived that but it's
not my recommendation the idea look the
ideal is that that you grow together and
you stay together it's a challenge
well my parents my parents were together
for 72 years
what if marriage is like every four
years you campaign and you ask family
whether you should stay together well
actually actually there is I do have a
variation on that you should if you're
married you should work to earn your
spouse's love just as you work to earn
their love before you were married never
take your spouse for granted that's the
single biggest piece of advice I could I
give people people get married and then
anything oh I got him I got her I don't
have to work to get her but you know
what my favorite word my favorite verb
urn I know singles who have a different
favorite verb but you know it's yes I
understand that but uh they'll get more
of that if they get married and do have
a good marriage respect very deep
message right there was spiritual
message what you just said right there
good well people want a lot of these
messages they go to my website they
could read my books like the rationale
Bible and they could go to Prager
University and listen to my there's a
lot of vehicles where I offer my
thoughts and I earn hopefully their
respect for
having some wisdom Dennis we're gonna
take this and we're gonna post this on
one of our YouTube channel so they can
find it folks if you want to find it
I'll post it on my Instagram for you
guys to see it if you missed the life
from the beginning when the dust settles
and everything settles down and we can
travel I look forward to our next
face-to-face visit with having your two
dogs on the show that's a deal we I love
that then its congratulations you have
officially done your first Instagram
live everybody go follow him and message
him for doing his first Instagram I
would love to hear from the people who
see this that's right okay take your
body good Tommy well my friend Oh bye
thank you so much